We'll we talk about packaging for a
second look.
That dot,
the heart of any university is its
faculty.
And with all of the developments,
you know,
if,
if you ask me what the major
achievements of mine now seven years as
president of Nyu are,
um,
I would say to you that the two
achievements of which I'm proudest are
number one,
the development of the faculty.
And number two,
the development of student life.
And we have had enormous transformation
even at Washington square on both of
those dimensions.
The heart of any university is faculty.
And then the key is to bring in really
dazzlingly talented students and make
sure they in the faculty interact.
And that's the formula you do that
everything else spotless.
And what ends up happening in,
in,
in today's world,
frankly,
is if you have the best faculty and the
most savvy,
smartest students,
they tend to yearn for the kind of
global network university that I just
described.
It emerges out of them.
The university president does not
operate in a command and control
environment,
at least this one doesn't.
I think what I'm good at,
sometimes he's noticing what people are
doing or inclined to do before they
realize it.
And,
and,
and then I'm a good storyteller,
so I tell a story of it that they
recognize and to which they then behave.
Eh,
so,
so everything that I'm describing about
Nyu as,
as,
as this global network university is
something that I've seen emerging from
my colleagues and from the appetites of
our students.
We can hardly keep up with the student
demand to study abroad.
Now,
how do you envision a faculty in this
Global Network University?
I've described?
Well,
it,
you know,
this is interesting.
I,
um,
I think that we're beginning to see the
emergence of a group that I called the
cosmopolitans.
What is a cosmopolitan?
Well,
a cosmopolitan is a person who sees a
life in an institution that allows him
or her and his or her family to move
around the world,
experiencing life through the Lens.
Not simply a single culture,
but many cultures that it's the kind of
person that enjoys traveling.
It's a kind of person that enjoys,
uh,
listening to ideas that a he or she has
never heard before,
whether he or she finds them inscrutable
or repugnant or wonderfully attractive
on first hearing.
Okay.
Do it.
The,
the,
the curious now,
a person who comes to Nyu or ready is a
person who's eager to live in an
environment like New York.
And the hypothesis is in New York is the
miniaturization of the world.
We,
we,
we already present complexity,
cacophony,
wonderful human cacophony,
not,
not cacophony,
that's grading,
but cacophony.
That's just my God aren't human beings,
you know,
amazing.
That kind of cacophony and,
and uh,
you know,
the,
that's the world that is coming because
the complexity and cacophony of
humankind is only going to become more
and more apparent.
And the question is,
can we make it symphonic?
So there's a certain group of people,
these cosmopolitans that,
that delight in that and,
and have,
uh,
an almost insatiable appetite for it.
So the bet is that among the very best
people,
you know,
call them if you want the no bell or the
Tony Level people,
you know that among that there's going
to be uh,
uh,
a substantial.
Now what does substantial meaning in
this case,
in this case,
substantial can mean 3%,
4%,
5% one in 20.
It doesn't have to be 12 and 20.
Okay.
Cause you're gonna only hire so many
professors even at the largest private
university in the world.
But,
but if you are the only institution,
or at least if you're the first mover to
become this global network university
such that a cosmopolitan can become a
professor at the institution and know
that he or she can have the benefit of
moving through the system.
You know,
with a certain amount of collegiality,
you have to check it out with your
department chair,
your dean.
But,
but the,
the,
the assumption is there that you'll be
allowed to move through the system,
that you'll be able to give your
children the benefit of growing up,
not as American Mano Linguists,
but a growing up on,
you know,
if you want to,
by the time they head off to college,
they could have lived on three different
continents,
you know,
all,
as part of a,
a kind of fabric of a professional life
at Nyu.
I actually think that we will attract
these cosmopolitans to Nyu in a
disproportionate way and that they're
likely to be among the most highly
talented professors.
So I,
instead of seeing the global network
university as presenting,
uh,
a challenge to faculty recruitment,
I see it as presenting an with regard to
faculty recruitment.
And of course the same thing will be
true of students.
We want to make sure we explain
ourselves to students.
You know,
we don't want some student coming in
who's expecting,
uh,
Notre Dame,
you know,
look,
now I'm a 50s Catholic.
I root for Notre Dame every Saturday in
the fall.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm programmed that way.
On the other hand is a reason Nyu does
not do division one athletics that is
deeply connected to its view of itself
as the Global Network University and a
complex society.
And that is that if you gather people in
a football stadium or a basketball arena
all wearing the same colors,
chanting the hymns that the cheerleaders
tell you to chant,
it feels very ozzie and Harriet to us.
It feels very 1950s.
It is not the 21st century,
a century of complex community.
And we don't want to give our students
easy community.
We want to value community,
tell them it's complex and then teach
them the skills of bridging and
tunneling out of their own micro
community to those other communities.
So instead of doing division one
athletics,
we give them exploration flaws in the
dorms.
What's an explanation?
Fluids.
All right?
We would never do an explanation floor
based upon the traditional dividing
things.
So we wouldn't have,
uh,
racially defined fluor or a religiously
defined flow.
But you want to live with students who
love jazz.
You want to live with students who love
the stock market.
Broadway theater.
We have 80 exploration floors defined
like that,
all students from different schools at
the university.
So there also a sudden now the bridges
and tunnels united by this interest
faculty member embedded,
uh,
er,
resident assistants embedded to build
programming each week around whatever
the unifying principle is,
influence silo.
Yes.
Out of the silo.
Otherwise,
shame on you.
Complex community interrelating
likewise,
that's what we're going to give you.
And this becomes an attracted to a
certain kind of student.
Not right for every student,
but a certain kinds of students.
So you have to explain yourself the fact
that you have to explain yourself to
students.
You have to tell them come complexity.
Community.
Yes,
but hard community.
That's what we're about.